même la ministre chers collègues nous
allons débuter notre audition
je rappelle que notre intervention de la
ministre et la commission pour lever
d'une retranscription sur le site
internet du sénat madame jacqueline
gourault est présente dans le cadre du
texte cadets dont est saisi le sénat qui
viendra en commission pour le rapport de
nos rapporteur pour la commission des
lois le 30 juin et en séance à partir du
7 juillet ou corriger c'est d'une bêtise
à partir du séduire propose demain la
vie de vous le sait tout de suite la
parole puis ensuite je donne la parole à
nos rapporteur monsieur d'arnaud madame
gatel ainsi que madame estrosi sassone
et puis naturellement les collègues qui
souhaitant s'exprimer
je vous propose de nous donner une heure
trente d'horloge on doit pouvoir y
arriver
merci à vous malo nice où vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
rapporteurs monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
est présent dans la salle mais je salue
aussi ceux qui sont sur l'écran
j'aperçois cécile
andré et jacques y voilà bonjour à tous
donc le projet de loi que je vous
présente qui relatifs à la
différenciation la décentralisation la
déconcentration et portant diverses
mesures de simplification de l'action
publique locale que j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter aujourd'hui est le fruit
d'un travail collectif riche qui a
appliqué une large partie du
gouvernement puisqu'il ya près de vingt
ministres et secrétaires d'état
sous la conduite du premier ministre qui
y ont participé il est né de trois
constats si je puis dire poser à
l'occasion du grand débat national
premier constat une attente très forte
de nos concitoyens à l'égard de notre
politique de renforcement de l'action
publique de proximité et j'ai l'habitude
de préciser que la proximité dans la
tête de nos collègues élus sur les
territoires c'est bien sûr leur propre
capacité à a
comment dire à être acteurs de l'action
publique mais la proximité c'est aussi
pour eux le rôle d'un état de proximité
d'un état de déconcentrer deuxième
constat une aspiration tout aussi
importante à une meilleure prise en
compte des particularités locales à une
organisation territoriale des politiques
publiques - uniforme et moins rigide
troisième constat une volonté des
acteurs locaux d'être confortés soutenus
dans leur mission est une forme je
dirais de fatigue à l'égard des grandes
réformes institutionnelles
après à un nombre de réformes
importantes je dirais ces vingt
dernières années voire même ces dix
dernières années et donc à la demande du
président de la république nous nous
sommes donc fixé pour obtenir a pour
objectif pardon de bâtir un acte de
décentralisation
adaptée à chaque territoire résolument
tourné vers l'action publique et non
vers une énième redistribution générale
des compétences
ce projet a été patiemment construit
depuis près de 18 mois dans la
concertation malgré la crise sanitaire
avec l'ensemble des ex des échelons des
collectivités et dans l'ensemble des
régions du territoire et y compris
l'outre-mer bien sûr se traduisant par
un titre entier dédié à la spécificité
de ces territoires que sébastien lecornu
défendra au banc avec moi
le projet de loi a également intégré les
attentes nouvelles qui ont été exprimées
à l'occasion de la crise du coc u19
notamment en matière de santé il répond
donc aux attentes pragmatique concrètes
et utiles formulées sur les territoires
et constitue une marque de respect
d'écouté de compréhension à l'égard des
élus locaux
je n'oublie pas aussi le travail fait
par le sénat et ses cinquante
propositions qui bien sûr enrichissent
ce que nous avons entendu sur les
territoires et qui d'ailleurs pour la
plupart du temps se recoupent
bien évidemment ce projet de loi marque
un tournant dans les relations entre
l'état et les collectivités
si l'état fixe un cadre et fourni une
boîte à outils concrètes à travers ce
projet de loi c'est aux collectivités
locales de saisir l'opportunité qui leur
est offert pour exprimer leur
singularité et leur projet leur projet
de loi traite en effet de la quasi
totalité du champ de l'action publique
locale en se concentrant sur les grands
défis auxquels les décideurs locaux font
face notamment les transitions la
transition écologique les mobilités
l'urbanisme et le logement la santé la
cohésion sociale et l'éducation
les quatre des en résume les objectifs
la différenciation territoriales pour
s'adapter aux réalités locales
elle se traduit par exemple par une
extension du pouvoir réglementaire
locales ou des mesures adaptées aux
enjeux transfrontaliers débattu l'art
je manque encore à l'occasion de la
journée de l'europe le 9 mai dernier ou
encore l'expérimentation d'un
financement différencié du rsa en
métropole
envisagé depuis longtemps et que la
différenciation permet enfin d'incarner
la décentralisation pour conforter les
compétences des collectivités
territoriales dans les domaines de la
mobilité du logement de l'insertion de
la transition écologique ou de la santé
à titre d'illustration les départements
les métropoles pourront se voir
transférer l'intégralité du réseau
routier de leur périmètre afin d'en
assurer la cohérence de gestion les
objectifs de production de logement
social de la loi sru applicables aux
communes seront pérennisés tout en
prenant davantage en compte les réalités
locales
le travail mené en commun avec
emmanuelle wargon qui portera le texte
avec moi sur ce volet a permis d'aboutir
à une proposition équilibrée qui
recueille je crois la santé mans des
élus locaux et je sais que c'est un
débat évidemment qui sera encore arish
enrichi par la réflexion du sénat et je
salue bien sûr dominique estrosi sassone
avec lesquels nous sommes un que nous
avons déjà travaillé ainsi qu'avec
valérie létard la déconcentration enfin
pour approcher l'état du terrain dans
une logique d'appui et de
contractualisation avec les
collectivités territoriales
alors je sais bien que tout cela n'est
pas forcément du législatif que ça peut
être uniquement du réglementaire mais le
gouvernent le gouvernement pourra
faciliter et c'est parfois nécessaire
par exemple le recours par les
collectivités aux capacités d'appui en
ingénierie du serema qui est un
établissement public de l'état et qui
nécessite pour cela une mesure
législative
autre exemple la parole de l'état sur le
terrain sera réunifiée en faisant du
préfet de région le délégué territorial
de l'ademe la dea complexification enfin
de l'action publique locale
voler que je porterai avec amélie de
montchanin et qui a été considérablement
renforcée au cours des derniers mois à
la demande du premier ministre sur la
méthode j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir avec le président du sénat
le président de la commission des lois
les deux rapporteurs de votre commission
françoise gatel et mathieu darnaud je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai déjà eu un
entretien avec dominique estrosi sassone
et valérie létard à l'occasion du
rapport d'information qu'elles ont méné
sur la l'évaluation de la loi sru et je
ne crois pas me tromper en affirmant que
nous sommes tous dans un état d'esprit
constructif et que nous voulons voir le
texte aboutir d'ores et déjà vous avez
dû retrouver une partie des propositions
que le sénat formulées dans les 50
propositions pour le plein exercice des
libertés locales
je crois que l'examen dans lesquelles
nous nous engageons nous permettra
d'aller encore plus loin puisque
plusieurs mesures pourront rejoindre le
texte initial sans difficulté d'autres
demanderont quelques ajustements pour
trouver bien sûr un point d'équilibré
évidemment nous avons aussi quelques
lignes rouges tout le monde a ses lignes
rouges sur lesquels je suis certaine que
nous allons revenir au fil de nos
échanges pour conclure le projet de loi
90 illustrera notre volonté constante de
poursuivre l'effort de transformation du
pays en s'appuyant sur les acteurs de
terrain qu'il s'agit des collectivités
ou des services de l'état en faisant
confiance à la démocratie locale
après la loi engagement et proximité
la déclinaison de nos programmes de
revitalisation des territoires l'agenda
rural la loi simplifiant les
expérimentations locales
la loi créant la collectivité européenne
désertent le projet de loi 4d viendra
parachever l'ambition que nous
partageons pour les territoires mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
remercie déjà car tous ces textes que je
viens de citer
on était approuvé par le sénat et je ne
doute pas que nous ferons encore un bon
travail avec la loi 4 d je vous remercie
merci la ministre je vais donner la
parole tout de suite nos rapporteur
peut-être en débutant par monsieur
d'arnaud s'il le veut bien même la tête
allez on varie les plaisirs merci
monsieur le président merci madame la
ministre
plusieurs points mais je vais être assez
succinct et rapide pour que l'ensemble
de nos collègues puissent s'exprimer sur
sur sur ce texte
le premier sujet vous avez fait état des
mesures concernant la déconcentration en
rappelant bien évidemment qu'il s'agit
essentiellement pouvoir réglementaire
pour autant c'est l'un des piliers de ce
texte intitulé cadets ou 3ds celui de la
déconcentration qui selon nous et nous
avons eu l'occasion de le dire et de le
redire va de pair avec la
décentralisation
pour ce faire nous avions notamment au
travers des 50 propositions formulées
par le sénat et le président du sénat à
l'été dernier insisté sur la nécessaire
articulation est nécessaire
complémentarité entre les préfets de
département et les maires pour autant il
y as pour nous un manque de souffle dans
ce texte il est essentiellement sur les
mesures de déconcentration notamment sur
le fait que s'agissant de certains
points notamment comme la possibilité
offerte pour l'attribution des
subventions en matière d'eau et des
agences de l'eau il s'agisse de remettre
le préfet de région
au centre de ces dispositifs là où nous
aurions souhaité considérant notamment
que les comités de bassins sont beaucoup
plus large que le périmètre des régions
et parce que la question de l'eau est
une question éminente sur la plupart de
nos territoires avec des enjeux qui sont
colossaux pour l'avenir dans nombre de
nos départements
nous aurions préféré que ce soit le
préfet de département qui puisse
être à la manoeuvre sur c'est sur ces
sujets comme nous aurions souhaité
notamment que s'agissant de la futur
office française de la biodiversité
là encore le préfet puisse être le
délégué territorial dans cette agence de
l'état de la même manière que nous
aurions souhaité c'est une demande assez
récurrente que ce texte encadre un peu
plus et élargissent leur hold et des
sous-préfets qui selon nous et on l'a vu
notamment à l'occasion des plans de
relance ont cette agilité nécessaires
pour être à l'écouté bien sûr des élus
de nos territoires mais de l'ensemble
des forces vives je pense notamment à la
question du plan de relance
autre point qui est un point majeur de
ce texte notre collègue daniel guéret a
eu l'occasion de vous interroger sur ce
sujet à l'occasion de l'audition de la
commission du développement durable il
s'agit du transfert des routes
nous avions alerté à cette occasion sur
la nécessité s'agissant des régions de
pouvoir réfléchir à augmenter la durée
de la période
d'expérimentation cinq ans nous
paraissant beaucoup trop court au regard
des enjeux au regard notamment de
l'évaluation des besoins
le cas échéant des transferts de
personnels et peut-être plus encore la
création
sas a considéré que la région
retransfert elle même mois au
département que la nécessité pardon
d'avoir la création d'un service dédié
donc ça c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
sommes assez assez vigilant parce que
nombreuses sont les sons les régions
soit par la voix de leur président ou
vice-président qui se sont exprimés en
ce sens considérant qu'il y a là un
écueil
un écueil majeur idem sur les mesures de
simplification il nous semble
aujourd'hui que beaucoup de ces mesures
de simplification son d'objets
disparates principalement sectorielle et
de portes et inégale souhaiteront donc
au niveau de la la commission des lois
peut-être leur donner un petit peu plus
de souffle afin qu'on n'aboutissent pas
à des mesures qui complexifie le
fonctionnement actuel qui est selon nous
inutile au regard du droit existant
enfin j'ai dit je serai synthétique un
dernier point parce que sinon je suis
sûr que vous seriez déçu que je ne la
porte pas s'agit de la question de l'eau
et de l'assainissement
vous connaissez notre avis négatif notre
volonté farouche sur cette question qui
est pour nous consubstantiel et de du
fonctionnement de nos collectivités et
de cette compétence eau qui nous ne
cessons de le dire plus encore que la
compétence assainissement ne relève pas
selon nous du périmètre intercommunal et
quand je le dis ne relève pas ne relève
pas tout le temps du périmètre
intercommunal puisque le constat
et frappant l'ensemble des collectivités
l'ensemble des communes qui souhaitait
transférer à l'intercommunalité l'ont
fait avant même le vote de la loi un
autre et peut finalement l'ont transféré
à partir de l'application de cette loi
c'est dire s'il y a des sujets mais vous
même la ville reconnue lors de débats
ici au sénat notamment que la compétence
eau à cette singularité qui nous oblige
à repenser ce transfert de compétences
notamment en direction de deux syndicats
plutôt que d'intercommunalité j'insiste
sur ce point je le dis parce que vous le
savez nous avons voté un texte à
l'unanimité nous avons toujours su
travailler avec avec le gouvernement sur
ce point pour essayer d'avancer mais
aujourd'hui on est devant un point de
blocage nous l'avions souligné lors de
l'examen du texte engagement un proxy
d'airé de proximité pardon considérant
que le principe de subdélégation serait
particulièrement difficile à mettre en
oeuvre
c'est pourquoi il nous semble
aujourd'hui qu'il est temps au regard de
l'évaluation et j'insiste sur ce point
et de la réalité
je crois qu'il est rare que le scénar
reviennent de façon récurrente sur sur
des sujets aussi aussi important pour
nous c'est le fruit de des remontées de
l'ensemble des élus concernés je pense
notamment aux zones de montagne je pense
notamment à des territoires dans lequel
est très complexe de transférer cette
compétence et au loup on s'orienterait
plus vert vers des syndicats que vers
l'intercommunalité voilà ce que je
souhaitais dire et je vous remercie de
votre écoute
merci ces derniers vendent gatel
beaucoup monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous vous l'avez dit récemment
le sénat accueil plutôt ce texte on va
dire avec bienveillance que vous avez eu
le mérite de tirer un fil qui n'était
pas simple sans doute mais aussi avec
exigence et je souhaite que nos travaux
y compris avec l'assemblée chat plutôt
positive ce que ce qui nous
semble c'est l'efficacité de l'action
publique donc nous nous poussons déjà le
texte vers la lettre e
d'autre part je voudrais dire d'une
manière générale mais avec beaucoup de
force et de conviction que la proche du
sénat ne consiste pas à détricoter des
lois qui ont été fait puisque c'est un
mot dont nous avons été souvent qualifié
de des tricoteurs et nous ne détricote
ont pas la république parce que en
affirmant l'intérêt de la
différenciation nous faisons la prose
que monsieur journal le faisait sans le
savoir puisque dans la constitution elle
même et dans les jurisprudences
on dit bien que la différenciation et la
diversité de moyens est utile pour
atteindre un objectif qui est celui de
l'égalité des droits et des devoirs pour
pour chacun donc c'est vraiment dans cet
esprit là que nous travaillons non je ne
sais pas si j'aurais autant d'audace
compétition que mathieu darnaud avec ce
marronnier du sénat qui est l'eau et
comme nous sortons quelques marronnier
comme disent les journalistes alors on a
l'impression qu'on peut parfois radoter
ou s'obstiner non c'est parce que preuve
est faite que ces questions que nous
posons reste très vrai et la crise
sanitaire a forcément montrer à la fois
une bonne a besoin d'articulation entre
l'état et les collectivités
mais surtout ce besoin de réactivité et
le fait que l'état peut avoir confiance
dans les collectivités qui ne faillit
jamais alors de valeur ma première
question porte sur les premiers articles
de ce texte le premier article
et justement relatifs à la
différenciation ans nous constatons si
je puis dire il n'y voyez là aucune
injure que c'est une sorte de
copier-coller de ce qu'ils ont à
constitution donc on n'apporte rien de
nouveau il n'y a pas de portée normative
dans la répétition de cet article alors
c'est bien ce que s'exprime le principe
de la loi
mais nous pensons que pour ceux qui
derrière nous interpréterons la loi que
nous aurons fait sans doute faut-il
mettre un peu plus de densité
l'article 2 qui est très important il a
trait aux pouvoirs réglementaires
locales
là aussi je pense que d'un commun accord
et pour cet objectif d'efficacité de
l'action publique on doit pouvoir aller
un peu plus loin on a vu comment pendant
la crise sanitaire beaucoup de de maires
et d'élus de petites communes on
utilisait un pouvoir réglementaire
locale qu'il se sente aux administrés
parce que sinon il n'y avait pas de deux
solutions une question aussi très
importante sur les étapes et donc
laisser happer ce sens c'est ce que
j'appelle des parloirs et c'est une fort
bonne chose qu'ils ont été instaurés
pour que les acteurs au niveau des
régions les départements la région et le
pays puisse parler et échanger
puisqu'ils sont touche contributeurs à
l'action publique et l'important qui des
espaces d'échangé de discussion
or on sait que c'était ap marche plus ou
moins bien
certains diraient qu'elle ne marche pas
du tout parce que s'interroge même sur
leurs intérêts et voix ne voilà-t-il pas
que dans ce texte on vient nourrir la ct
ap d'une chape de compétences qui n'en
serait pas vraiment une mais il a s'est
tapé deviendrait un lieu ou une fois par
an une fois tous les six ans un an après
les élections régionales on viendrait de
discuter de transfert de compétences
donc ces données à cette étape est une
contribution un peu vague mais qui
risque d'être une entrave à la liberté d
à la liberté des territoires sur le
deuxième point sur la décentralisation
madame la ministre je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir l'écrire avec un d majuscule et
avoir un peu d'audace parce que je pense
à la médecine scolaire
le gouvernement a une politique très
volontaire en faveur de la prévention et
en faveur de l'enfance chacun se réjouit
de ça
les départements une compétence assez
remarquable qu'ils exercent avec
beaucoup de professionnalisme mais
aujourd'hui on sait que les
établissements pour la petite enfance
sont à la fois gérée par les
départements mais qui n'ont aucune
autorité sur le personnel parce que ce
n'est pas le département qui choisit le
directeur ce n'est pas le président de
département qui l'évalué c'est président
du département qui rémunère comment
peut-on demander un département d'avoir
d'exercer avec efficacité un service de
prise en charge des enfants quand ils
n'ont pas l'autorité enfin la médecine
scolaire
nous sommes absolument devoir être un
peu musclé parce qu'elle est quand même
très indigents et que nous pensons que
les départements qui ont toutes les
réponses et que les nombreux services
qu'il gère doit pouvoir aller toucher
des enfants qui ont des difficultés des
fragilités des enfants qui sont
invisibles parce qu'il ne consulte pas
alors qu'à l'école on est certain que la
médecine scolaire serait là dans
l'intérêt des enfants
le troisième point alors là c'est mon
marronnier comme l'eau et
l'assainissement de mathieu darnaud
c'est celui de l'assouplissement du
fonctionnement des intercommunalités
je sais que vous n'aimez pas beaucoup ça
madame la ministre nous nous y revenons
ouais mais la deuxième partie ma faim
alors moi je les aime tellement madame
la ministre que je souhaite que
l'interco soit heureuse et que même la
dcf a beaucoup évolué et la cchit parce
que la desservent reconnaît qu'il y a
une obligation de performance et
d'efficacité et que beaucoup de choses
doivent être faites et peuvent être
faites à l'échelle de l'intercommunalité
mais parfois il faut une intervention de
proximité et que l'échelle de l'interco
qui est parfois très grande n'est pas
l'échelon le plus performant alors moi
je vous parlerai bien sûr vous le sait
bien
du nid-de-poule métropolitain je ne suis
pas sûr que la performance de la
métropole se reconnaissent à la manière
de boucher le trou de la 48e rue de la
77e comme et là ça me fait beaucoup rire
mais c'est quand même un vrai sujet
et que je pense que l'intérêt metropolit
a mérite d'être interrogé et quand je
vois le rapport de la cour des comptes
sur les métropoles où la cour des
comptes s'étonne qu'il y ait autant de
délégation de gestion entre une
métropole et des intercoms et que ça
n'est pas extrêmement légal de prolonger
ses délégations de gestion au delà on va
dire d'un âge de maturité de la
métropole ça veut bien dire que les
faits montrent que les communes et leurs
intercours ont réinventé des solutions
totalement étrange et curieuse parce que
la totalité de la compétence avait été
transféré de manière autoritaire à la
métropole et on aura la même question
sur les cias dont on parle dans ce texte
enfin les ressources humaines dont
disposent les collectivités
j'en ai j'en ai un peu parlé les
directeurs d'instituts départementaux
pour l'enfance qui sont rémunérés par
les départements mais qui sont quand une
fois nommés par une autre autorité
évalués par une autre autorité
je suis pas sûr que ça fonctionne
vraiment bien moi je pense que il faut
pouvoir élargir le détachement non
seulement aux directeurs de ces
établissements mais au directeur adjoint
parce que si seul le directeur est sous
l'autorité du département mais que tout
le personnel qui dépend du directeur ne
dépend pas du département on va avoir un
problème
et enfin une question très important qui
a trait la déontologie alors la hache un
tvp ne manquent pas en ce moment de
comment dire d'imagination de
préconisations qui quand même pousse un
peu à l'absurde sur la notion de délit
de prise illégale d'intérêt donc
naturellement il n'est pas dans l'idée
du sénat de contester la prise illégale
d'intérêt la transparence la prudence
voilà on est bien d'accord là dessus
mais quand même je dire l'interprétation
de la loi faite aujourd'hui par la hache
et tvp sous la forme de préconisations
fait qu'à un moment
les élus ne pourront même plus être élus
aucune décision ne sera prise parce
qu'on confond ou en étant la prise
illégale d'intérêts à la défense ou à la
représentation de la commune d'un
délégué dans des sociétés d'économie
mixte et on confond intérêt général et
intérêt privé dont nous nous penchons
madame la ministre qu'il faut redéfinir
la prise illégale d'intérêt et il faut
qu'on déroge à cet article en faveur des
élus j'disais qui représentent leurs
collectivités au sein d'une scène où en
êtes vous de vos réflexions je donnerai
un dernier exemple puisque il se trouve
que la semaine dernière deux élus de la
ville d'angers ont été auditionnés par
un juge pour prise illégale d'intérêt
alors qu'ils avaient parce qu'ils
avaient participé à des à la préparation
de délibération ayant trait à des
missions locales où il représentait leur
commune donc je pense qu'il y a urgence
à agir pour sécuriser l'action publique
est protégé de manière légitime les élus
merci madame la ministre monsieur mêmes
biens tels madame estrosi sassone merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
donc je vais aborder pour ma part le
titre iii du projet de loire qui est
relatif à l'urbanisme et au logement sur
lequel nous aurons à débattre avec nous
même madame la ministre mais également
avec votre collègue madame emmanuelle
wargon ce titre iii il compte deux
sujets importants
la réforme de la loi sru et des
dispositions sur les attributions de
logements sociaux
sachant que les autres dispositions qui
sont contenus dans ce même titre sont
beaucoup plus technique est en tout cas
certainement moins sensible
politiquement
donc je voudrais vous poser trois
questions sur la réforme de la loi sru
le projet de loi ouvre la possibilité
d'un rattrapage différencié pour chaque
commune déficitaires en logements
sociaux à travers un contrat de mixité
sociale qui est signée entre le préfet
et le pci pourrait-on aller plus loin
dans la différenciation et là des
concerts
ration en donnant plus de marge de
manoeuvre aux acteurs locaux que ce soit
sur le rythme de rattrapage sur ce que
le contrat de mixité sociale peut
prendre en compte pour atteindre ses
objectifs et ses conséquences pour être
plus simple est ce qu'on peut musclé ce
contrat de mixité sociale pour faire du
couple maires préfets l'élément central
de l'application de la loi sru
deuxième question le 29 janvier à grigny
monsieur le premier ministre a déclaré
qu'il était très favorable à une vision
intercommunal de l'application de la loi
sru
alors on sait bien là encore que toutes
les intercommunalités qui de plus en
plus ont toutes les compétences dans le
domaine du logement et de l'habitat et
qui deviennent donc non seulement les
chefs de file mais presque des autorités
organisatrices des politiques publiques
de l'habitat néanmois ces
intercommunalités ne sont pas toutes au
même degré de maturité pour autant est
ce que la réflexion du gouvernement à
évoluer sur ce sujet et d'après vous
pourra-t-on mettre en place dans la loi
puisque aujourd'hui rien n'est prévu
dans le texte tel qu'il arrive ici au
sénat sur donc une expérimentation en la
matière sur la vision intercommunal de
l'application de la loi sru
et puis toujours dans ce même discours
de grigny pour garantir la mixité
sociale
on peut considérer que sur ce point là
la loi sru n'a pas eu loin s'en faut les
effets escomptés
le premier ministre s'est déclaré
également déclaré en faveur d'une
limitation des logements très sociaux
dans les communes où il y à déjà plus de
40 % de logements sociaux
seriez vous favorable à l'inscription
dans la loi de ce principe d'une loi sru
à l'envers ou cela pour vous doit-il
rester au niveau de simples consignes au
préfet qui vous remercie
merci mais je vous propose de la parole
tout de suite quand même le ministre
pour répondre aux trois rapporteurs puis
ensuite je ferai la parole à madame
kuperman monsieur al sharq et monsieur
sueur même la ministre l'a pas bien
merci beaucoup alors d'abord mathieu
darnaud a parlé de déconcentration et je
le remercie et pour lui dire
bien évidemment que nous sommes d'accord
sur le renforcement du rôle des préfets
de département ce qui bien sûr ne veut
pas dire qu'on va supprimer les préfets
de région je jeu j'extrapole mais je le
disais mais parce que quand il y en a
qui y en a qui quand même bon jusque là
donc je je je je je voulais le le
préciser donc nous sommes d'accord très
sérieusement pour renforcer le rôle des
préfets dès jeudi bien des préfets de
département et d'ailleurs comme vous
l'avez vu par exemple quand nous avons
fait la haine c'est et moi j'ai voulu
que ce soit le préfet de département qui
soit le délégué territorial de l'agencé
nationale de cohésion des territoires
alors dans ce texte nous faisons du
préfet de région le délégué territorial
de l'ademe
comme vous le savez c'est une nouveauté
puisqu'il devient délégué territorial de
l'ademe et je crois que c'est une avance
je vois bien ce que vous voulez dire
vous auriez préféré que ce soit le
préfet de département et mais je pensais
quand vous avez dit tout à l'heure il
faut un peu plus de souffle j'ai déjà
beaucoup soufflé si je puis dire pour
obtenir un certain nombre de décisions
et
je crois que évidemment le préfet de
région délégué territorial de la dance
est aussi une manière de recevoir une
délégation pour conclure une convention
avec les collectivités au nom de l'
agence et participer à l'évaluation
évidemment de toute cette politique est
évidemment en lien avec les préfets de
département sur la présidence des
conseils d'administration des agences de
l'eau par le préfet de bassins la
présidence du conseil d'administration
de l' agence de l'eau confie au préfet
coordonnateur du bassin où l' agence a
son siège et renforce également le rôle
des préfets dans la lèbe l'élaboration
du programme pluriannuel d'intervention
de chaque agence et là encore je pense
que le fait que le préfet de région et
cette mission renforce aussi le rôle des
préfets des départements sur l'office
français de la biodiversité
il a semblé au gouvernement que cet
office était trop jeune pour pouvoir
pour aller le modifier déjà c'est à dire
laissons le vivre un petit peu en ce qui
concerne mais ceci dit je suis d'accord
avec vous sur le rôle des préfets de
département en ce qui concerne les
routes et la période
de d'expérimentation qu'est ce que j'ai
fait de mon jeu propose de papier pour
te le dire c'est pour pas oublié mais
sur la période d'expérimentation
naturellement je suis ouverte on prend
cinq ans parce que c'est la moyenne des
expérimentations en général mais si vous
trouvez que c'est trop juste trop court
je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient enfin
joue pour moi ça n'est pas du tout un
blocage
évidemment tu as dit à beaucoup de
simplification qui sont fait qu'il ya
des petites choses
il ya des choses de porter inégale c'est
vrai je moi je le je le reconnais mais
comme vous avez le diable se cache
parfois dans les détails et il ya des
petites choses qui sont en fait
importante dans le fonctionnement de la
vie de tous les jours et le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales et naturellement sur le
volet simplification nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts à des propositions que vous
pourriez nous faire sur la
simplification pour compléter ce
ce paragraphe il ya aucun aucun problème
et je pense quand on rentrera dans le
détail qu'il ya un certain nombre de
choses
vous verrez qu'ils sont intéressantes
sur l'eau et l'assainissement
c'est effectivement jeu depuis je suis
ministre j'ai déjà beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet et avant d'être ministre
quand j'étais au sénat on a beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet voilà c'était
bien mais il ya deux choses parce que il
faut pas qu'on se trouve dans la
discussion la loi engagement et
proximité de décembre 2019 a déjà comme
tu l'a rappelé d'ailleurs un traité de
ce problème
je rappelle aussi en fait ton
explication c'est de dire la dimension
c'est pas toujours la dimension
intercommunale
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça
j'ai aucun problème et que parfois un
syndicat est mieux à même d'être à la
dimension d'un bassin versant
par exemple alors je me souviens avoir
fait chez plus dans quelle loi déjà fait
passer à baisser le niveau
deux syndicats à l'intérieur le niveau
le nombre d'intercommunalités pour faire
un syndicat pour passer de 3 2 je vous
rappelle plus dans quelle loi j'ai
travaillé là dessus mais enfin je les
fais bon alors bien sûr on parle de
l'eau l'assainissement c'est un autre
sujet comme tu l'as dis toi même le
sujet de l'eau c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui pensent pas que c'est pas assez
grand lot il ya des gens qui pensent que
c'est c'est l'intercommunalité c'est
trop grand et tu le sais très bien si on
ouvre le problème de l'eau et de
l'assainissement
il ya la tentation de ceux qui
voudraient faire en sorte qu'on revienne
sur ce qui a été fait dans la loi
engagement et proximité c'est-à-dire au
niveau des communes comme tu le sais et
ça ça n'est pas possible on va pas
réouvrir se débat encore une fois c'est
ça n'est pas possible
alors après sur les bassins versants et
les intercommunalités
je sais que dans certains territoires et
au nom du principe de différenciation
je ne peux pas dire que c'est quelque
chose que je ne peux pas comprendre
voilà ensuite françoise alors françoise
d'abord m'a parlé des articles qui
servent à rien c'est à dire l'article
assidus mais on se connaît suffisamment
pour que le dise enfin que c'est un
article de principe parce que les
jurisprudences était méconnu et c'est à
des fins pédagogiques
c'est vrai mais je pense que c'est très
important de le faire fou car je veux
dire ça ne s'annulent earth personnes
cet article peut-être que son objectif
et dans le respect du principe d'égalité
je me penche vers l'écran pour voir
notre collègue dans le respect du
principe d'égalité de reconnaître aux
élus davantage de marge de manoeuvre
pour exercer leurs compétences
la différenciation con
lui apporter des s'assouplissement à
l'uniformité des règles d'attribution et
d'exercice des compétences au sein d'une
même catégorie de collectivités
territoriales et je crois que c'est bien
de le rappeler et de rappeler aussi le
principe d'égalité qui parfois peut
inquiéter a contrario un certain nombre
de nos collègues sur la différenciation
alors ensuite sur le pouvoir
réglementaire donné aux élus locaux cet
article est conçu comme un article
d'appel et de méthode
il a vocation à être complétée par
d'autres exemples bien sûr permettant
concrètement de donner plus de marge de
manoeuvre à une simplification elle une
décentralisation des règles s'appliquant
au champ des compétences des
collectivités locales le sénat a
d'ailleurs a déjà fait des propositions
qu'on regarde avec intérêt et comme vous
le savez je vous l'avais dit je crois
nous avions missionné l'inspection
générale de l'administration pour
qu'elle puisse nous apporter d'autres
exemples concrets dans le champ des
compétences des collectivités elles ont
travaillé tous les codes qui est un
travail assez ardu et on a des
propositions qui sont qui sont faites on
a eu le rapport tout à fait récemment
et naturellement nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à travailler avec vous sur les
propositions qui sont faites par des
juristes qui disent bas ça c'est
possible c'est de la compétence des
collectivités
on pourrait transférer le pouvoir
réglementaire
ensuite françois sur l'article 3 sur la
ct ap nous avons fait un article sur la
cpap parce que on est persuadé que la ct
ap ne fonctionne pas comme elle devrait
fonctionner je rappelle que c'est la loi
map tam qui avait créé la ctrp la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique et j'ai l'habitude de dire que
je connais pas beaucoup de régions où ça
fonctionne
par la bretagne je dois le reconnaître
sur françoise et que souvent ça a été
appelé cette espèce de grande messe
annuelle quand ça sera unie parce que
c'est pas toujours le cas
et donc nous avons pensé qu'il fallait
modifier et le gouvernement pense et je
pense personnellement que c'est très
important qu'il y ait un lieu où les
collectivités territoriales peuvent se
réunir régulièrement et discuter entre
elles
entre les différents niveaux de
collectivités territoriales ce qu'on
parle toujours des relations entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
mais il ya aussi la nécessité d'un
travail horizontale entre les niveaux de
collectivités territoriales jeu je peux
vous dire que je suis parfois assez
estomaqué mais pour avoir été dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits et beaucoup
de régions
j'ai rencontré des endroits où les
présidents de région ne parle pas avec
les présidents de départements ça me
semble peut-être bizarre mais j'en
connais je les ai vus comme on dit et le
gouvernement se propose donc d'étoffer
les compétences des s'était appelé sans
remettre en cause leur équilibre
pour que les élus continuent de
s'approprier cet outil et qui permettait
aux céréales et non pas d'avoir des
compétences
c'était ap ne peut pas avoir de
compétences mais de discuter entre elles
deux délégations de compétence qu'elle
pourrait être amenée à se faire et nous
avons pensé qu' il fallait les centres
et sur la réalisation de projets qui
existent sur les territoires cette
délégation pourrait être proposée par
tous niveaux de collectivités et ouvrir
donc des possibilités de délégations
jusqu alors qu'ils sont cloisonnés et
donc ça permet très régulièrement à des
collectivités sur des projets précis de
pouvoir s'entraider se décider elle-même
de ce maître de se transférer une
compétence pour moi je ne sais pas
construire un grand jeu pas un ensemble
numérique sur le territoire d'une région
bon voilà et c'est l'objet de cette ct
ap voilà mais on peut peut-être
clarifier encore la rédaction si vous la
trouvez pas suffisamment précise les
mesures de souplesse dans les opci alors
d'abord moi j'ai une conviction c'est
que des mesures de souplesse existe déjà
qu'elles sont nombreuses et quelquefois
elles ne sont pas bien connus et
utilisés et ce sujet a été déjà traité
d'ailleurs dans engagement et proximité
et il est vrai que nous pensons que dans
le cadre actuel de fonctionnement
il ya déjà de nombreuses adaptations qui
peuvent se faire dans le fonctionnement
des intercommunalités
par exemple le pc peut se doter d'un
service commun avec une ou plusieurs
communes mans ce service est en principe
géré par le pc mais peut être confiée
une commune les peu les opci peuvent
réaliser des prestations de services
pour leur compte pour le compte des
coureurs le conte pardon de leurs
communes membres et inversement
le président d'un opci peut déléguer
l'exercice d'une partie ses fonctions à
des conseillers communautaires même de
manière territorialisée n'empiète de
nombreuses mesures de souplesse qui
existent et qui je pourrais aller plus
loin et je pense que ré ouvrir ce
dossier risque de nous amener à des
choses qui sont compliqués je rappelle
par ailleurs que le texte de décembre
2019 a de façon heureuse me l'obligation
d'une conférence des maires et je crois
que c est quelque chose de très
important
ensuite nous avons sur les conflits
d'intérêts alors vous vous m'aviez déjà
saisi de ce sujet mathieu aussi et donc
nous avons évoqué ce sujet avec la haute
autorité et nous sommes en train de
travailler avec eux mais tout de suite
je voulais vous le dire la haute
autorité évoque un sujet de cohérence
avec le code pénal
oui me dit le spécialiste qui est à côté
de moi
et donc il faut que nous reparlions de
cela pour voir quel est le texte qui
serait utile de
qui pourrait porter cette mesure parce
que nous sommes d'accord sur l'analyse
ensuite la médecine scolaire
alors je veux pas tout le monde le sait
ici ou à peu près tout le monde
la médecine scolaire a été un moment
dans le texte initial
donc je veux pas dire le contraire
puisque nous pensions
que l'articulation de la médecine
scolaire avec les compétences du
département en matière de sentiers de
petite enfance via les pmi pouvait faire
qu'on imaginait que la médecine scolaire
pouvait être transféré au département il
y a eu beaucoup de réflexion dans le
cadre de l'élaboration du projet et je
dirais qu'on l'a appuyé de chiffres
précis puisque aujourd'hui on conseille
on considère que seuls 18 % des élèves
ont bénéficié de la visite médicale
d'entrée en sixième bon je dis bien
réalisé par un médecin évidemment visite
médicale réalisée par un médecin
donc la santé scolaire aujourd'hui
repose sur 966 équivalents temps pleins
de médecins scolaires et de 8000
équivalent temps-plein d'infirmiers pour
des raisons je dirais comme tout ce qui
concernait la santé au moment de cette
préparation de la loi
il a été comment dire défendu que ça
n'était pas le moment de changer les les
organisations de santé
bon voilà ça a été une décision qui a
été comment dire décider voilà
alors sur le logement
alors je voulais dire que les
contraintes big cité sociale que j'ai
pris des notes
je pense que j'ai fait mais le contrat
mythes et de mixité sociale permettront
un rattrapage différenciée selon la
situation locale le taux de 30 3% du
déficit pourra être ramené à 25%
donc alors c'est ça tu trouves que c'est
trop élevé mais c'est possible
ce qui est important de rappeler c'est
que les contrats de mixité sociale vont
désormais exister dans la loi qu'ils
sont déconcentrés et que c'est lé préfet
plus les avis locaux qui compteront et
non plus les décisions nationales qui
remontait à une commission nationale
donc je pense que l'article 18 parle
d'un examen conjoint maire préfet des
difficultés rencontrées cela donne
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre à mon
avis localement pour gérer ces contrats
de mixité sociale
et je pense que les articles
cet article est très important c'est
l'article 18 et nous proposons
d'ailleurs de renforcer ce dispositif
pour en faire un véritable levier de
différenciation en matière de politique
de construction de logement social et je
pense que on en discutera 1 mais c'est
déjà une avancée considérable par
rapport à la situation antérieure
en gros c'est une manière de régler
localement les sujets pour avoir vécu ça
de très près je pense que c'est une
grande avancée par rapport à la loi sru
alors nous avons ouï sur
l'intercommunalité
alors il existe déjà et tu l'as dit vous
l'avez dit parlant dominique la réalité
fait que les intercommunalités ont des
compétences par l'ondé plh par exemple
évidemment qui se vont au niveau des
intercommunalités et il existera deux
dispositifs pour mutualiser les
rattrapages les plh et les dispositifs
de notre collègue marc-philippe
daubresse que tu connais et dans un
certain nombre de territoires et nous
sommes ouverts améliorer le dispositif
des plaies lâche et à l'écouté des
propositions
je voulais quand même dire je le dis
parce que nous n'avons pas eu de la part
des associations d'élus des propositions
ce que nous avons dit on est ouvert à ce
que l'intercommunalité d'un rôle plus
important
on n'a pas eu de retour donc bon je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui qui qui
s'inquiètent aussi du rôle que pourrait
jouer l'intercommunalité un à qui le
voient comme une souplesse mais il y en
a d'autres qui le voient comme une
contrainte
donc nous sommes ouverts à étudier les
propositions évidemment sens dévoyé
l'objectif que chaque commune s'engage
fortement et sans transférer les
obligations aux communes qui ont qui ont
déjà beaucoup de logements sociaux et
puis vous avez parlé
quatrièmement de ou troisièmement les
logements les communes qui ont 40 % de
logements sociaux
voilà la loi sru à l'envers le premier
ministre a pris l'engagement au comité
interministériel effectivement des
villes à on était dans l'essonne à
grigny pardon voilà et
et donc il ya une circulaire qui a été
prise elle est prise
la circulaire oui elle est pris ça pour
arrêter les agréments dans les communes
où il ya déjà 40 % de logements sociaux
donc je dirais la demande est satisfaite
voilà
alors évidemment je crois qu'il faut
alors peut-être faire attention aussi je
le dis parce qu'il y avait un argument
qui qui avait été soulevé aussi à grigny
c'est que il faut parfois les communes
qui ont déjà 40 % de logements sociaux
demandent tout de même à construire des
logements sociaux intermédiaires 1 on
est bien d'accord
voilà utiliser votre micro même s'il
vous plaît au lieu de faire des pl ayew
des plus on peut effectivement faire du
ps ou du logement intermédiaire voilà
bien merci madame la ministre
alors je vais de la parole même que
kerman oui merci sur président madame la
ministre quatre remarques sur ce que
vous avez dit est ce qu'ils ont déjà été
dit par le rapporteur
tout d'abord oui effectivement vous avez
raison il y avait une volonté notamment
chez risée du locaux qu'il n'y ait pas
de nouvelles grandes réformes et qu'il y
ait besoin d'une pause institutionnels
ce qui ne veut pas forcément dire qu'il
fallait ne rien faire et qu'il ne faille
pas au contraire travailler un
renforcement de ses libertés locales il
ya une meilleure capacité pour pouvoir
permettre aux locaux de mieux répondre
aux besoins de leurs populations et donc
finalement on arrive dans cette femme
quinquennat sans grandes réformes avec
quand même le sentiment que sur beaucoup
de choses
il faudrait bousculer ce qui d'ailleurs
parfois peut très bien se passer sur ce
qu'il faudrait bousculer davantage parce
que ça ne se passe pas bien
eh bien l'on est encore hésitant ou en
tout cas au milieu du gué vous nous
parlez d'un nouvel acte de
décentralisation mais j'ai eu beau
relire les nombreux articles de ce
projet de loi je cherche encore où et
comment l'on justifie un nouvel acte de
décentralisation c'est à dire dans
l'esprit des grandes lois de
décentralisation ce qui vise à renforcer
finalement les libertés
donc on citoyennes de notre cause de nos
concitoyens dans un cadre bien
évidemment républicain et surtout dans
leur capacité en lien avec les élus
locaux à s'approprier la chose publique
et à travers les temps électoraux le
temps des mandats
cette capacité à construire dans la
proximité
les différents en réponse aux à travers
notamment les services publics locaux
qui peuvent être faire toi par les
communes les départements où que par les
régions et je rajouterais pour une fois
ces personnes ou les groupements de
communes sur la question que mathieu
darche ont évoqué de la déconcentration
elle est inévitablement le parallèle
d'une véritable décentralisation et
pardonnez moi madame la ministre mais la
déconcentration ne peut se résumer
simplement un renforcement du pouvoir
des pros des préfets juste ils les
préfèrent départementaux quand on voit
ce qui se passe depuis maintenant
quelques années dans nos départements
c'est une désertification de l'état et
ce n'est pas les maisons france service
qui règle la question
on a aujourd'hui des restructurations
dans les dg fip qui fragilise
l'accompagnement dans la technique et
l'ingénierie financière des élus et dans
la construction budgétaire est compris
dans des situations budgétaires de plus
en plus tendu un affaiblissement de la
capacité notamment à travers les
nouvelles ddt de répondre sur une
certaines problématiques et ce n'est pas
la seule à ntt qui peut répondre à cette
à ce recul pardon de la présence de
l'état et ses véritables déconcentration
il faut c'est bien évidemment repenser
cette présence d'un état que je vais
qualifier un état fort dans nos
départements les qui n'est pas là pour
être un et ascenseurs qui n'est pas pour
être un état empêcha mais qui ôte au
contraire doit être là pour être l'état
accompagnateurs accompagnateurs de
l'exercice démocratique que sont censés
et doivent mettre en oeuvre pour la
durée de leur mandat les différents élus
locaux alors je finirai sur la question
de la simplification
parce que là aussi on y met ce qu'on
veut bien évidemment cette
simplification va se faire dans un cadre
de l'égalité
la première des simplifications serait
serait pas bien accueilli dans sa
générale préparer la région on pourra vu
qu'elle est tellement caisson à travers
différentes crises successives la dune
intérieur ajoute eu d'engagement et de
foot et la possible vente inondations
pouvoir intervenir sur la compétence est
connue dans la question de l'eau qui a
été abordé la meilleure des santés
situation est justement de revenir qu'à
un revers très souriant et et empêche
finalement bon déploiement été happés
dans une simplification à faire sur la
certainement d'être supprimés ils
tellement hyper fourré à l'époque pour
elles ont besoin de se défouler la
métropolisation elle qui a rassuré ceux
qui finalement était inquiet de la
disparition des autres territoires
la mamie très sincèrement à la veille de
zurich sur locale
nous allons avoir un plus gros corps
d'abstention je crois qu'ils en ont tiré
les enseignements de certains noms de
voix à force d'avoir corseter les
libertés locales rien dévolu aux
problèmes de la crise politique nous a
par contre les petits bobos cadre d'un
débat démocratique à devoir résoudre de
toute urgence car c'est une forte
abstention
allez merci kuperman monsieur andré
reichardt première si monsieur le
président bonjour ans nommé ministre
je voudrais intervenir sur un retour sur
les 3 premiers articles de ce projet de
loi et si vous le permettez je le faire
bien entendu en qualité de sénateur du
bas-rhin sénateur alsacien avec un
prisme liés à la différenciation et tout
particulièrement à vos compétences de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace créée
par cette loi de sur l'article 1
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
je n'ai pas rajouté à ce qui a été dit
notamment par françois sagat
c'était un article inutile
allez on va dire qu'il n'a pas beaucoup
de portée normative et en tout état de
cause
à mon sens il ne va pas très loin en
matière de différenciation et donc ma
question sénateur alsacien je me répète
est la suivante dans la mesure où le
projet de loi en matière de
décentralisation pour le coup prévoit
d'assurer le transfert de certains blocs
de compétences et clarifier la
répartition de ces dernières c'est ainsi
indiqué dans dans l'exposé des motifs
pourquoi ne pas avoir profité de cet
article premier pour compléter la
différenciation notamment de la
collectivité européenne dallas dans
certaines de ses compétences jeu bourré
naturellement cité un certain nombre
d'exemples ont passé d'un rôle de chef
de file à un rôle plus dense la plus
simple à comprendre mais entre autres
exemples la cea collectivités
européennes
ascom les les autres départements à des
compétences bien sûr sociale pourquoi ne
pas avoir par exemple permis ne serait
ce qu'à titre expérimental à cette
collectivité européenne d'alsace de
faire aussi de l'économie de proximité
du commerce de proximité j'ai entendu
mathieu darnauzan parler tout récemment
dans une édition précédente afin de
faire un bloc cohérent de tout cela
c'était ma première question sur
l'article 2 3 il fait l'obligation
région de convoquer là c'était ap on a
d'ores et déjà en la cause de cette ct
ap mais quand même une question pour ma
compréhension même si cher chez cher
ministre vous avez déjà répondu
franchement à quoi ça sert à quoi ça va
servir à quoi va servir cet article 3
puisque la cette étape et a désormais
l'obligation sur convocation du
président de région nouvellement
et le une obligation de mettre au débat
si la loi le principe de délégation de
compétence collectivités une autre et
après une résolution peut être adopté
par la majorité
et lorsque cette résolution le cas
échéant est adoptée les collectivités
intéressées peuvent procéder aux
délégations de compétence mentionné
alors franchement moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre je suis pas du tout polémique
à quoi va servir cette procédure puisque
les collectivités territoriales ne
seront pas liés par cette résolution si
elle est prise et en outre et vous le
savez bien
nous avons d'ores et déjà au code
général l'article 1108 qui prévoit les
délégations de compétence le problème
pour moi et j'illustre en alsace avec
avec le grand test
c'est pas une question de deux
possibilités de mettre en oeuvre des
délégations pour mettre en oeuvre une
délégation il faut que le délégant
veuille bien déléguer il ça va pas nous
aider beaucoup
enfin je termine sur l'article de projet
de loi prévoit certes quelques petites
extensions du poids réglementaire en
alsace moselle
vous savez nous avons un droit local qui
actuellement n'évolue pas on ne peut
plus évoluer
n'y aurait-il pas eu lieu et on peut
peut-être peut-être encore le faire
avant la ministre n'y aurait-il pas lieu
de chercher à le faire évoluer de deux
façons en renforçant par exemple le rôle
de la commission du droit local qui à ce
jour d'ailleurs n'est pas encore
reconstitué c'est pas faute pour tous
les élus alsaciens de l'avoir demandé je
ne sais pas pourquoi ça n'avance pas
mais deuxième deuxième question est ce
qu'il ne serait pas possible de
transférer à la collectivité europe et
d'audace pour ce qui concerne l'alsace
et au département de la moselle puisque
nous avons endroit transférer donc les
compétences en matière de droit local
qui relève du pouvoir réglementaire
voici possibilité qui pourrait vraiment
coûte rien en l'espèce et c'est
transférer les dispositions du droit
local en matière réglementaire à la ceva
et au département de la moselle
je crois que sauf en disant ça je dorme
de tout esprit partisan
on aurait bien mérité de la glace au
gouvernement jour merci merci ce rachat
monsieur sueur si monsieur le président
je voulais me permettre madame la
ministre de poser ou d'aborder deux
questions premièrement une question de
philosophie générale les règles les lois
en vigueur permettent d'ores et déjà ce
que j'ai regretté que qu'une commune
transfert une compétence une
intercommunalité une intercommunalité à
une commune l'une et l'autre un
département un département à une commune
une intercommunalité à une région cela
introduit quelques confusions et voyant
les débats qui se déroulent actuellement
je vois que de plus en plus d'instances
demande à exercer de plus en plus de
compétences ou de parties de compétences
par exemple il y a des problèmes de
santé
les communes s'y intéresse c'est normal
monsieur le maire ou madame le maire est
constamment sollicité les départements
bien sûr les intercommunalités
évidemment les régions disent pourquoi
les communes auraient le droit de
salarié des médecins les départements et
pourquoi pas les régions mais n'y at-il
pas le risque finalement que l'on
aboutisse à une grande confusion et je
voulais vous demander quel était votre
philosophie
finalement est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
est inéluctable de s'orienter vers une
confusion des pouvoirs ou peu un peu il
n'y a plus de compétences véritablement
dévolu à un niveau où est-ce que vous
rester attachés à ce qui fut finalement
un postulat de la décentralisation au
débat à savoir que chaque niveau de
collectivité était responsable d'une
compétence ou deux
chaque compétence chaque compétence est
associé à un niveau c'est une question
de philosophie
y compris d'ailleurs par rapport au rôle
de l'état
parce que la claire définition du rôle
de l'état et des compétences de l'état
peut apparaître quelque chose de
précieux même si ce peut être une
facilité et où un avantage pour l'état
de voir toutes les collectivités vouloir
se saisir d'une partie de ses
prérogatives
c'est la première question c'est une
question de philosophie pour savoir
finalement quel est votre horizon à cet
égard deuxièmement je voulais vous
interroger sur les métropoles
je sais qu'il a été décidé au départ de
ne pas aborder certains sujets la
démocratie est quand même un sujet qui
est là et on vote toujours au suffrage
universel direct dans une commune de 60
habitants et tout le monde y tient
beaucoup
et vous avez des collectivités qui
compte plus d'un million d'habitants qui
ont des prérogatives bien supérieure à
celle de toute commune et même de la
commune centre et pour lesquels il
n'existe pas d'élections suffrage
universel je n'ai pas de position
simpliste pour ma part à ce sujet par
exemple je pense que dans les
communautés de communes la proximité
avec les communes fait que le système
actuel me paraît fonctionner et pouvoir
être pérennisée en revanche dans les
grandes ces métropoles
il y à un cas qui est celui de lyon que
notre président que des biens où il a
été décidé de mettre en oeuvre une
démocratie au niveau de la métropole je
crois pas que la démocratie soit
mauvaise je pense qu'elle est bonne e
et alors il ya deux choses qui ont été
décidés finalement une chose et là le
vote au suffrage universel dans la
métropole est la question posée
posée j'ai dit je n'étais pas favorable
pour les communautés de communes
mais pour un certain nombre de très
grandes entités est-ce que ça n'aurait
pas finalement un sens et est ce que ça
n'a pas un sens dans le cas lyonnais
et puis on a décidé concomitamment autre
chose qui est que la métropole se doter
des pouvoirs du département sur le
territoire de la métropole
je ne suis pas persuadé que ces deux
choses soit forcément liées elles sont
liées de fait parce que dès lors que la
métropole en dos les compétences du
département
il faut voter normal elles deviennent
collectivités locales
mais c'est pas forcément liés et comme
je vois qu'il y ait des débats là dessus
certains sont partisans de généraliser
le système lion au métropole
d'autres me disent que non qu'il
faudrait c'est comme cela et je sais
qu'on n'aborde pas ce sujet mais ce
sujet il est là et il viendra de toute
façon donc j'aurais bien aimé savoir au
delà de cette loi qui n'en parlent pas
finances vosges et doit quelle est votre
philosophie à ce sujet dernière
intervention monsieur régulier oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mon propos il y aura un peu dans le
prolongement des propos de du président
sueur mais simplement sur un focus plus
précisément sur la métropole
d'aix-marseille et pour corroborer un
peu les propos ne devra porter et donner
un peu de sens à ce qui ce qu'il a été
dit de manière concrète la métropole
d'aix-marseille quand on regarde
l'intercommunalité des bouches du rhône
effectivement en 1966 on n'a pas pris le
virage des communautés urbaines c'était
une volonté à l'époque de de gaston
defferre et la création de
l'intercommunalité sur sur les bouches
du rhône en tout cas sur marseille et on
va dire très très récente puisqu'elle
date de 2000 après les lois chevènement
mais si j'en reviens plus propre et plus
précisément pardon à la création de la
métropole d'aix marseille
on s'est aperçu que cette métropole à
statut particulier
prenez dans son périmètre des
compétences dites de proximité je vous
donne un seul exemple l'extension des
cimetières communaux les bornes incendie
les chemins des fci et on s'est très
vite rendu compte dans les mois qui ont
suivi la création de la métropole que
ses compétences à l'échelle de la
métropole ne pouvait pas être exercés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
formalisé le plus vite possible
208 convention de gestion pour les 92
communes que composent la métropole je
vous rappelle que c'est la métropole la
plus vaste
vous connaissez quatre fois plus grand
que le grand paris 6 fois plus grand que
le grand lyon et en même temps nous
arrivons à un point de blocage puisque à
juste titre le préfet de région a émis
un recours gracieux sur ces conventions
de gestion
il a apprécié le caractère illégal il a
totalement raison
ceci dit on arrive à un point de blocage
puisque la métropole n'est pas en mesure
de reprendre en gestion ses compétences
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que il faut véritablement remettre sur
la table ce débat réviser en profondeur
la formation de cette métropole
parce que les élus ont évolué sur cette
question je pense que toutes les
compétences dites stratégiques
on voit bel et bien l'intérêt de
l'exercer sur les 92 communes que ce
soit les documents de planification
urbaine on parle du scot du plh du ps
lui en revanche des compétences dites de
proximité exercée sur ce périmètre l'un
ne fonctionne pas et qui plus est
derrière le redécoupage des compétences
de savoir qu'est-ce qui est compétences
dites de proximité qu'est ce qui est
compétences stratégiques
il ya aussi l'organisation de cette
métropole il ya la notion de conseil de
territoire mais derrière l'organe pour
sultats tiff il ya aussi l'organisation
déconcentrés des services de cette
métropole donc je pense que c'est
véritablement un travail de long terme
mais qu'il faut un statut cours pour
l'heure sur ces conventions de gestion
sinon va arriver très vite en point de
blocage c'est à dire le nom l'exercice
de ses compétences de proximité est
également ne pas je pense clairement
effacés le fait que le périmètre de la
métropole doit être sujet également
interrogation si jamais on arrive à des
compétences dits stratégiques pourquoi
pas élargir cette métropole à l'échelle
du département et bien même la ministre
vous avez alors zut
voilà cécile pour cécile thurman qui dit
que bon elle ne voit pas où vous via de
la décentralisation dans le texte
je voulais lui dire bien évidemment que
il y a de la décentralisation si on
prend les le texte la décentralisation
sur le plan réglementaire il y à la
décentralisation des routes
il y a des décentralisations qui sont
dans le domaine de
la transition écologique etc mais
j'assume absolument totalement que c'est
une loi qui n'est pas une grande loi de
décentralisation
d'abord parce que j'ai une conviction
profonde que je vous exprime à nouveau
puisque j'ai une conviction profonde
d'abord un il y a un jour où on se
heurte au mur si je puis dire de des
compétences régaliennes de l'état et que
tout ne peut pas être décentralisées que
deuxièmement il y a eu deux de grande
époque de décentralisation et de grandes
lois de décentralisation et
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
république décentralisée s'est même
inscrit dans la constitution et qui a
beaucoup de choses qui sont gérés par
les collectivités territoriales
troisièmement je vous le dis aussi
simplement que cela quand j'ai rencontré
j'ai rencontré à peu près 2000 élus
pendant tous ces consultations
je n'ai pas trouvé d'appétence
particulière pour une demande de
décentralisation très forte et sauf dans
certains domaines dont il a été question
tout à l'heure sur la médecine scolaire
je dis pas qu'on peut pas en faire plus
mais je dis qu'il ya un moment aussi où
fo faut relativiser la demande des élus
sur sur la décentralisation
troisièmement ou quatrième enjeu plus le
marqueur de notre loi c'est la
différenciation c'est ça et je pense que
quand on fait les contrats de solidarité
sociale par exemple mais c'est comme non
mixité sociale j'étais enceinte de
tromper on fait de la décentralisation
ou de la déconcentration sans le dire si
je puis dire
est-ce qu'on transfère les décisions du
national au local
donc je pense que nous avons fait un
travail
à ces fins si je puis dire de travail
pour faire en sorte que cette loi soit
un équilibre entre la différenciation la
déconcentration et la décentralisation
je voudrais aussi dire à alain petit
kerman et que ça me permettra de
répondre à jean pierre sueur sur la
philosophie de ma pensée je ne suis pas
pour le retour de la clause de
compétence générale aux régions et aux
départements je le dis haut et fort
et évidemment ça répond à ta première
question et je pense que la loi notre
qui a été une loi enfin qui a été très
décriée et pour certains de ses aspects
nous avons partagé cette idée mais pour
d'autres sur la clarification
c'est quelque chose d'abord je voudrais
vous le dire sur lesquels les élus et
les associations d'élus ne veulent pas
revenir
je tiens à le préciser dans toutes les
auditions que nous avons entendu ensuite
sur andré les questions d'andré
reichardt andré la première chose que je
voudrais te dire c'est que je suis allé
pour la mise en place de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace il y a quelques
semaines si les dires et que donc la loi
commence seulement à s'appliquer c'est à
dire la création la collectivité
européenne d'alsace vient d'être mis en
place qu'en ce moment vous êtes comme
partout en france dans les élections
départementales puisque la collectivité
européenne d'alsace ça a été la fusion
de deux départements
et vous allez avoir osé lui bientôt
votre nouvelle comment dire votre votre
nouvel exécutif d'élus et je pense que
il faut laisser à la collectivité
européenne d'alsace le temps de
s'installer de vivre et de voir comment
cela fonctionne parce que c'est pas
parce que on va pas dans une loi
immédiatement revenir sur ce qu'on vient
de faire
alors évidemment un certain nombre de
choses qui ont été évoqués par toi je
voudrais rappeler que nous avons fait
cette collectivité européenne d'alsace
dans un cadre constitutionnel constant
et que nous l'avons fait sur le principe
de la différenciation parce que c'était
un territoire en plus frontaliers donc
s'il y avait une révision
constitutionnelle peut être qu'on aurait
pu aller plus loin mais là nous sommes à
quand un cadre constitutionnel constants
et sur l'a7 et ap article 3 on s'inspire
de ce qu'on a fait en alsace puisqu'elle
permet des délégations de partis de
compétence par projet et c'est ce qu'on
a fait exactement pour la cia et en
respectant bien sûr le principe
fondamental de notre tutelle d'une
collectivité sur l'autre c'est comme ça
c'est un principe constitutionnel sur la
la commission du droit local
alors ça je voulais tout simplement te
dire que la ca ou une collectivité ne
peut pas se voir transférer des
compétences législatives bien sûr et je
voulais te dire aussi que les élus
locaux ne nous l'ont absolument pas
demandé et
c'est un sujet je pense enfin je pense
très sérieusement que on ne peut pas
revenir sur tout ça alors qu'on vient
d'installer la collectivité européenne
d'alsace jean pierre sueur j'ai déjà
répondu sur une partie sur les
métropoles et ça permet aussi bien sûr
de de parler de la métropole de
marseille dont vous venez de parler
alors jean pierre a parlé du suffrage
universel alors ça c'est un sujet qui a
été installé sur la collectivité la
métropole de lyon pardon parce que c'est
une métropole à statut particulier comme
tu l'a rappelé étant donné ce que ce
n'est pas marseille
étant donné que nous avons fusionné le
département et
le
la ville la communauté urbaine et après
l'élection au suffrage universel des
métropoles ont c'est un sujet
effectivement qui qui se pose est kif à
mon avis fera partie du débat politique
avec la fin comment dire
les prochaines réformes
institutionnelles qui pourront qui
pourrait se faire et la métropole de
paris comme la métropole de marseille
parlons clairement sont des sujets qui
méritent qu'on revienne dessus parce
qu'il ya des réformes à faire parvenir
aux gt avec vous quand on a fait la
réforme de la métropole de paris est la
réforme de la métropole de marseille et
est un vrai sujet qui est posé
tu n'empêchera pas que si tu commences à
parler de ça pour les intercommunalités
que sont les grandes métropoles que ça
se pose ensuite jusqu où on s'arrête
communauté urbaine
après communauté d'agglomération et tu
as dis toi même que tu pensais que
c'était pas utile pour les communautés
de communes mais enfin quand on va
commencer à changer le mode de scrutin
pour certaines intercommunalités je
pense que ça risque quand même de se
développer sur d'autres niveaux
bon je sais pas le débat ça sera pas le
débat de cette loi mais je répondais
puisque tu m'as volé posé la question je
crois que
sur la métropole de marseille on sait
tous que le système ne fonctionne pas
bien
c'est très clair et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons mis un article 56
dans la loi avec l'idée que c'était au
fond 1
un débat qui devait enfin une question
qui devait être posée au sujet de la
répartition des compétences entre la
métropole et les conseils de territoire
à mon sens c'est 208 délégation montre
qu'il y a évidemment à
dysfonctionnements et vous l'avez vous
même exprimé la métropole a du sens pour
porter des projets structurants et notre
article d'ailleurs ouvre la discussion
pour trouver un équilibre entre la
proximité que nous pourrions reconnaître
dans certaines compétences et redonner
bien sûr aux communes mais il est il est
important enfin si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire dans le débat politique de ne
pas comment dire saucissonner les
décisions il faut qu'on ait une vision
globale c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui doit
aller au niveau métropolitain et qu'est
ce qui doit être éventuellement
redescendu au niveau local comment mois
et est donc
je pense que la situation actuelle
mérite qu'on oblige qu'on prévoit un
débat obligatoire à mi mandat sur les
délégations de compétences et sur le
fonctionnement de la métropole y compris
sur son périmètre on sait très bien que
la métropole de marseille couvre en gros
le département des bouches du rhône sauf
le pays dalle mais pour connaître et
pour avoir déjà rencontré le nouveau
maire d'arles
je sais ce qu'il en pense il m'a répondu
mais au fond un jour pourquoi pas mais
pas dans la métropole comme elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
ça va exactement dans le sens que vous
êtes en tint en train d'exprimer donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas mis au
programme de ce texte la métropole de
marseille et la métropole de paris on
l'a mis sciemment et évidemment je pense
que c'est une réforme
cerrell ces deux réformes métropolitaine
enfin exige que l'on fasse un gros
travail exige que l'on trouve des
solutions communes
je vais changer je vais parler de paris
je suis frappé de la diversité des
positions qui sont pas des diversités
politique à l'intérieur même des partis
politiques
il ya des gens pour certaines solutions
et d'autres pour d'autres et comme vous
vous avez comment on appelle ça des à
paris des trucs intermédiaires les oeufs
péter ça y est
et vous vous avez des conseils de
territoire bon il ya un moment on peut
ce quand même se poser des questions et
ça mérite vraiment une réflexion
apparaît un texte à part c'est pour ça
que nous si j'ai bien compris le sens de
votre intervention c'était à non pas
d'un faux pas bricoler sans travail
voilà voilà voilà
je crois que l'essentiel bien merci à
mme la ministre
alors y at il d'autres questions n'en
voit pas le cas je vois que nous sommes
dans le timing que nous sommes fixés
c'est que c'est déjà un succès merci
pour ces précisions et pour toutes les
questions qui ont été posées
[Musique]